Alright guys, so for an example, number 2 for the weekly bias, I'm looking at GPP NCD,
so you can see we took out the extended liquidity right here, where is the draw on liquidity.
So this tiny probability gap that you can see right here, if I zoom in, you can see there's
this gap right here, that is going to be a draw on liquidity, so let's drop down to
the 4 hours time frame, remember for the weekly, we go from weekly to 4 hour time frame.
This is when we took out the liquidity here, that is going to be this right here, if it
breaks, that is going to set our bias, and right here, what do we have, we have a market
structure shift, right?
So now, once this broke here, that would be our bias, till this liquidity level is hit,
so now where we could have entered from this bread and butter model, this fair value gap
right here, that I see right in the premium, and let's see, if price goes there, right
there, boom, price goes into the fair value gap, and we have our draw on liquidity hit,
so let's go to the weekly taproom once again, I'm going to show you another example, that
just happened, just around here, so what happened here, we took out extended liquidity here again,
and we have this fair value gap, right?
We could use the 0.5 level of this fib, because that is some part of it, the fair value gap
is inside the discount, so we should be using the 0.5 level, let's go to the for our time frame
and look for what have happened here, so right here, we can see we have this fractal low here,
and we also have this fair value gap, so price took out the extended liquidity, we have a market
structure shift, setting our bias, right, this is the fair value gap that we take our entry from,
right, this fair value gap is filled, and this is the only fair value gap that is left,
so we simply take our entry from this fair value gap, we put our shop right above this high,
or you can put it here, doesn't matter, and use target this level, which is our draw on liquidity,
and let's see how this plays out, and price hits our take profit level, very simple guys,
so let's move on to the daily example number two now.